- À 57 ans, Mario Pelchat
souffre d'une maladie
dégénérative qui entrave
ses mouvements. N'empêche,
il savoure une liberté
qui lui a bien manqué
à l'ombre des barbelés.
MARIO PELCHAT, ancien détenu
- Les premières années
de prison, je m'en suis
voulu beaucoup.
- Mario a eu une enfance
difficile. Longtemps,
il a gelé ses souffrances
avec de la cocaïne, drogue
qu'il fallait payer.
Il commet un vol qualifié,
est arrêté et condamné.
- Mais... je ne m'attendais pas
à ce qui suivrait.
- Pour avoir poussé un gardien,
en 2017, Pelchat passera
29 jours consécutifs
en isolement cellu
c'est-à-dire 23 heures sur 24
en cellule, seul.
Après 15 journées consécutives,
l'ONU considère l'isolement
cellulaire comme une forme
de torture.
- La détresse que je pouvais
ressentir...
- Cinq ans après son séjour
au trou, Mario Pelchat peine
toujours à trouver les mots
pour décrire l'angoisse
qu'il y a vécue,
mais il l'a dessinée.
- C'est moi qui suis désepéré.
- Désespéré au point
de s'auto-mutiler avec
des lames de rasoirs.
- C'étaitiens, tu...
Vous pensez que je suis
de la merde? Regarde.
C'est ça que je mérite?
Pour qu'on soit reon soit reon u
à m'enfermer dans des cages...
- En 2020, les tribunaux
ont condamné le Service
correctionnel du Canada à verser
plus de 28 millions de dollars
en compensation aux détenus
qui ont vécu de l'isolement
entre 2009 et 2019.
CLARA POISSANT-LESPÉRANCE, avoc.
Trudel Johnston & Lespérance
- Les juges ont dit que d'êtrete
isolé, d'être sans contact
humain pendant 23 heures sur 24,
ça portait atteinte
aux droits fondame
Et les juges ont dit :
"Ça vaut de l'argent. Il faut
que les gens qui ont vécu
de l'isoent
indemnisés, soient compensés."
- Dans ce cabinet du Vieux-
Montréal, tous les jeunes
avocats du bureau sont
mis à contribution dans
une singulière course
contre la montre.
ANNE-JULIE ASSELIN, avocate,
Trudel Johnston & Lespérance
- On a déjà 750 réclamants,
mais en fait, c'est 750sur des ,
on trouve ça dommage qu'il
y ait plein de gens qui ont
le droit de recevoir
une indemnité parce que leurs
droits fondamentaux ont été
violés et qui peut-être n'ont
pas entendu parler du recours
collectif, ne savent pas qu'ils
ont de l'argent qui leur est dû.
Donc, le but, vraiment,
aujourd'hui, c'est vraiment
de leur dire : réclamez!
- En 2019, l'isolement
cellulaire a été aboli
dans les pénitentiers fédéraux,
mais il serait toujours utilisé
dans les prisons gérées
par Québec. Un nouveau recours
collectif contre le service
correctionnel provincial, cette
fois, est d'ailleurs en branle.
- Wow!
- À Sherbrooke, Mario Pelchat
s'émeut de ces luttes
judiciaires.
- Ça vient te chercher?
- Bien, oui, parce que
c'est atroce.
- Ici Émilie Dubreuil,
Radio-Canada, Mo